yo what is happening i'm lying on my
living room floor right now
and i'm just desperate to get a message
across
and this message if you get this
it will change everything okay
the biggest key to success
the biggest key to success the thing
that 99
of people haven't got and won't do
is write this down engrain this on your
brain
it's implementation implementation
what i mean by implementation
implementation just means taking
massive action taking massive action
like i'll tell you something i remember
running the training program a few years
ago
i run a training program a few years ago
and there was there was two people
sat next to each other this in the same
training program
okay two people sat next to each other
one of them
went on to become one of the most
successful property entrepreneurs in the
uk
his name's alistair cunningham you
probably know him
really good friend of mine the other
person alice says
business partner not a business partner
partner on the course i was teaching the
course they were partnered up
she okay she not only does she fail
miserably in property
she failed miserably in property she
actually went on to blame me
she said oh samuel's cause was not very
good okay but i'm thinking hold on a
minute and at the time it really hurt me
i'm like
why does she leave me a bag of you what
happened she was on the same course
as i was there and alistair went on to
build
you know i mean she's understanding 200
property deals
just last year it's like
how did she go on the same training well
the difference was alistair
took action now you're watching me on
youtube i love that i appreciate you
being a subscriber of mine
but i see sometimes some of the in the
comments so
the same people have been watching me
for a year or two and they haven't done
anything
and it pains me i did a video just
yesterday
okay the last day of november it was
called the seven ways
to get the low market value property
deals
how to find bargain properties i talked
about how to get deals from estate
agents
how to find leads and the thing that
pains me
the videos had a couple thousand views
and
i know out of the 2 000 people that
watched that video yesterday
i know they'll only probably be 20 that
will actually
implement and do what i
said on the video everybody else would
just be like is this a good video
you know oh um you know i don't know
what they're thinking
so and there's there's a saying it says
if you don't
if you don't use it you lose it what
that means is if you've been given some
knowledge
or if you've been given an opportunity
and you don't use that opportunity you
don't
use that knowledge that you've just
received you're going to lose it it's
going to disappear
so every time you learn something new
this is my biggest advice i can give and
this is what i did when i was 17.
when i started on property every time i
learned something new about business
about negotiations about
anything i would immediately
like straight away i would apply it and
the reason i do this youtube video by
the way just for the record
is because i genuinely get a kick out of
seeing people win
that's why i do the youtube channel now
there's all kinds of people you know
skeptical people out there thinking
you know someone was just doing this
maybe to try and get extra money or to
try and sell courses or trying to no
i mean i've been i wasn't able to run
courses for the most of 2020
but i'm still doing a youtube video
every single day um i don't even
hardly run ads on this on this channel i
could be running ads and
getting sponsors i don't do that i'm not
saying i will never do that because i'm
a businessman
don't get me wrong i like to make money
but the reason
i run this youtube channel the reason i
teach people is because i want to see
people win
and it's because when i started in
property
uh when i was a teenager i remember
thinking why is it so hard why are
people so
you know and ask basic questions i say
where do you find your deals
where do you get your deals from how do
you negotiate how do you do this how do
you structure this and
and everyone will be answering in
riddles and keeping their cards super
close to their chest
and i remember finding quite difficult
in the early stages and i just thought
if ever i become successful if everyone
make it i'm just going to be so
transparent about how to do it i'm going
to share freely
and the thing is i do share freely i've
run training programs for free g's we've
got a property investors crash course
i'm running this month
and it's free it's a one pound booking
thing
and over those two days i'm just gonna
be teaching teaching teaching teaching
showing doing deals sharing and
that's what i do that's what i'm about
and it is honestly the
biggest reason that people don't succeed
the knowledge is out there
the biggest reason people don't succeed
is because they don't implement the
knowledge
they don't grab the opportunity i don't
know what that is maybe they're afraid
to be rejected um it's really funny
because at the property investors crash
course and i hope to see you there by
the way i hope you i hope you're booked
on but at the property investors crash
course
i um i don't just teach what i'll do is
i'll
i'll i'll teach something and i'll say
does that make sense does everyone
understand
everyone's like yeah yeah i understand
there's gonna be hundreds of people
there
and then i'll say right let me show you
now that this works in the real world
someone give me an area someone will
shout out an area you know
um middlesbrough or whatever and then
i'll jump online
big screen and i'll show i'll implement
on the spot
and i'll show how it works and
everyone's like yeah great oh wow
oh brilliant fantastic i know i
understand i said no you don't
understand
you don't truly know this until you've
done it yourself so guess what we have
such long days at the crash course guess
what's going to be happening right now
and it was like uh what
now it's your turn now it's your turn
and then literally everyone's going to
get their laptop out their phones out
and they're going to be doing deals
exactly how i did
um from stage of the crash course that's
how we do it because the thing is with
the
the thing is when i do it like that i've
realized that when you force people to
implement
people don't like it a bit uncomfortable
but when you force implementation
the true way someone learns something is
by doing it themselves
you know so hey by the way if you're not
booked on the crash course tickets are
almost sold out
i literally just a few days ago booked
it
and was like hey we're running the crash
course and i i put on two dates
two dates and uh you know it it's big
it's the ibis hotel in london really
really really big hotel room it will
hold um
i mean usually we get about one to two
thousand people in the room
but because of social distancing and the
pandemic
we have to spread the chairs out but
we've still got we've got a capacity of
500 people
and we've sold for over 500 tickets
already
over 500 tickets gone and uh luckily
we've got two
we've got two crash courses but they're
both over half sold out
so get registered implement right now
this is the opportunity
right now implement right now and you
know i'll leave a link
in the description implement what you
see on youtube you know take
action take action uh that's that that
is the biggest lesson i can give you so
don't be like one of those people
who hear something can just don't do it
if you come to the crash course i'm not
gonna let you not do it you come to the
crash course it's gonna be like here's
how you do a buy to let here's how you
work out the return investment
here's how you structure a lease option
agreement here's and you're going to be
doing it at the program people say it
sounds too good to be true samuel why
would you do that for free or for a
pound
if it sounds too good to be true it
probably is you know it probably is
that's what they say well listen if
that's your attitude if you think
if it sounds too good to be true it
probably is let me tell you something
nothing good will ever come your way
because every time something good comes
up
you'll sabotage it even a relationship
it might be the you're like oh my gosh
this person seems amazing
it's not almost too good to be true and
then you'll sabotage it you'll find a
something wrong with it you know maybe
you're you'll say and people do that
with the crash course i've run the
property mr scratch was completely free
people just trying to find a reason you
know what's the problem what's the catch
maybe there's an upsell i mean sure that
that there are additional
options to do further training if i tell
you something the property investors
crash course is two days
value packed content rich for two days
and that's why you know we've had over
20 000 people
attend from all over the world so i
really hope to see you there at the
crash course i really want you to win
i really want you to implement and i've
been there and done it by the way
i've you can check in company's house
last year
my company turned over just shy of 10
million pounds
um net profit of over 2 million pounds
profit
i've done over 300 property deals um the
vast majority of my wealth
is in real estate is in property over 90
of my students are really really happy
uh obviously not everybody if you want
everybody's cup of tea then you'd
probably be a merc
so i'm not everybody's cup of tea i get
it some people say something what do you
shout what is it
but listen um property investing is very
doable
it's very very doable there's a massive
opportunity right now
in the market massive the opportunity of
a decade is right now
and um i really really want to see you
so get yourself booked and i'll leave a
link in the description
um i've got two dates in london don't
make excuses
just be there just be there and i can't
wait to meet you i can't wait to shake
your hand
and if you've got questions about
property let me know let me know your
questions
jump on youtube but when i give you the
answer go and implement
you know go and implement so anyway i
appreciate you guys
love youtube love sharing peace out
thank you for watching
and i'll leave a link in the description
get yourself booked on it literally is a
pound
there's so many messages from people
samuel what's the catch though how much
is it actually once you've paid the
pound how much did
it the pound for two days i'll see that
get booked on